ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้า
สวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนครูฟ้าคะวันนี้วันนี้วันอะไร
คะวันนี้วัน
จันทร์ค่ะวันนี้วันจันทร์วันที่เท่าไหร่
คะวันที่ 18 เดือนอะไรคะเดือนเมษายน
ปีพตอะไรคะปีพต 2  5  6 ห้าปีคศอะไรคะปี
คศ 2  022 ค่ะ
เมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะเมื่อวานนี้วัน
อาทิตย์วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 17 เดือน
5 เมษายน
มีผช
2565 ปีคศ 2  022 ค่ะพรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะ
พรุ่งนี้วันอังคาร
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 19 เดือนเมษายน
ปีพตต
2565 ปีคศ 2  022 ค่ะค่ะแล้วตอนนี้เวลา
กี่โมงคะครูฟ้าตอนนี้เวลา
9:00 น 9 โมงกี่นาทีคะ 30 นาทีค่ะ
9:30 นก็เป็นเวลากลางวันแล้วก็เป็นตอน
เช้านะคะตอนเช้าครูฟ้าตื่นแล้วใช่ไหมคะ
ถ้าตื่นแล้วค่ะตื่นตื่นแล้วนะติน่าน่าน่า
ตื่นตาตื่นสมองตื่นตื่นแล้วครูหญิงตื่น
หรือยังคะผู้หญิงตื่นแล้วค่ะตื่นแล้ว
เหมือนกัน
ว่าตายเราสองคนต้องสอนภาษาไทยนักเรียน
อายนักเรียนตื่นหรือยังคะ
ตื่นแล้วนักเรียนบอกก็ตื่นแล้วอยากเรียน
ภาษาไทยแต่ว่าวีดีโอนี้เนี่ยเราสอนนัก
เรียนระดับบีกินเนอร์
ให้หาซื้อนักเรียนระดับ beginner นะคะ
เป็นบีกินเนอร์ Class
ตายค่ะเนาะแต่ว่าถ้าเราสอนถ้าเธอมีเดียต
Class
แต่ไม่ใช่วีดีโอนี้นะหาเวลาที่ครูหญิงกับ
ครูฟ้าเนี่ยมีคลาสอินเทอร์มีเดียท
ถ้ามีคลาสตอน
10:00 น
ฟาสอินเตอร์ Media
10:00 นครูหญิงกับครูฟ้าก็ต้องตื่นตั้ง
แต่
07:00 น
ตื่น 7:00 นเลยเหรอคะใช่ค่ะเรามีคลาส
อินเทอร์มีเดียทเราก็ต้องคิดเอง Just พูด
อะไรจะสอนอะไร
อินเทอร์มีเดียทเนี่ยมี topic  E เป็นแบบ
history
สุโขทัยอยุธยา
ครูหญิงกับครูฟ้าก็ต้องตื่น
7:00 นและตื่นเร็วๆ
โห
7:00 นตื่นแล้วก็หาหา
topic ในอินเตอร์เน็ต Google ใช่ไหมหา
topic ในอินเตอร์เน็ตอาอาศ topic อ่าน
หนังสือ
สายอินเทอร์มีเดียทคลาสครูหญิงกับครูฟ้า
เนี่ยต้องอาหาร
อ่านหนังสือหรือมากๆ
รูฟ้า
อะไรคะก็คือฟ้าชอบอ่านหนังสือไว้คะเนี่ย
มีหนังสืออันนี้คือหนังสือหรือนะคะแล้วก็
ครูฟ้าเนี่ยอ่านอ่านหนังสือไม่เห็นใช่ไหม
อ่านหนังสือครูฟ้าชอบอ่านหนังสือไหมครู
ฟ้า
ท่ออ่านหนังสือหรือถ่ายนักโอ๊ย
ลูก
ผู้หญิงมีหนังสือเป็นหนังสือใช่ไหมคะเป็น
หนังสือตายผู้หญิงเนี่ยมีหนังสือเป็นเล่ม
สมัยเป็นเล่มเป็นหนังสือแล้วก็มีกระดาษ
ใช่ไหมคะมีกระดาษมามีตัวหนังสือภาษาไทย
แต่ครูพระอ่านหนังสือใน
ebook
อ่านหนังสือใน E  Book นะคะเป็นอย่างนี้
หนังสือ
มันก็ค่ะค่ะผู้หญิงอะไรดีฟ้าอ่านอ่าน
หนังสือทุกวันไหมคะกูฟ้าเนี่ยวันจันทร์
อ่านหนังสือวันอังคารอ่านวันพุธอ่านวัน
พฤหัสบดี
วันศุกร์อ่านวันเสาร์อ่ะสุขสันต์วัน
อาทิตย์ไม่อ่านหนังสืออ่านหนังสืออ่าน
หนังสืออ่านหนังสืออ่านหนังสืออ่าน
หนังสืออ่านหนังสือก็คือถ้าวันจันทร์วัน
อังคารวันพุธวันพฤหัสบดีวันศุกร์วันเสาร์
วันอาทิตย์ครูฟ้าอ่านหนังสือคือครูฟ้า
อ่านหนังสือทุกวัน
ไหม
ครูฟ้าไม่อ่านหนังสือทุกวัน
ไม่ได้ 1 อาทิตย์เนี่ยนะ 7 วันครูฟ้าอ่าน
หนังสือหรือวันอะไรบ้าง
วันเสาร์
ค่ะวันเสาร์
เลี้ยง
ครูฟ้าบอกว่าครูฟ้าท่ออ่านหนังสืออ่ะ 1
อาทิตย์ครูฟ้าก็เพราะอ่านหนังสือ 1 วัน
วันเสาร์โอเค
ในวันเสาร์วันวิทย์ผู้หญิงไฟดับเหรอ
อากาศวันเสาร์วันเสาร์ทำไมครับผู้หญิงวัน
เสาร์ที่ครูฟ้าอ่านหนังสือ
ครูฟ้าอ่านกี่ชั่วโมง
[เพลง]
รู้ฟ้าอ่านหนังสือกี่ชั่วโมงแล้วนักเรียน
ดูพระอ่านหนังสือ
3 ชั่วโมง
30 นาที
สาวชั่วโมงครูฟ้าอ่านหนังสือ
เดี๋ยวเราอ่ะค่ะ
กูฟ้าคะทำไมคุณอ่านหนังสือแค่
30 นาที
30 นาทีนิดหน่อย
แล้วรู้สาวพวกครูฟ้าชอบอ่านหนังสือ
คือครูฟ้า
ชอบนะคะชอบอ่านหนังสือ
เมื่อก่อน
เมื่อก่อนให้คือแพภูฟ้าอายุ
17  18
หนึ่งกูฟ้าชอบอ่านหนังสือนะแต่ว่า
ตอนเนี้ยกูป่าวเนี่ยเป็นไฮเปอร์
Hyper ไอ้เปอก็คือแบบกูฟาไม่ค่อยโฟกัส
ใช่มั้ยเวลาอ่านหนังสือนะคะไว้แล้วแบบอ่ะ
ก็
ขอ
มันไม่โฟกัสรู้สึกแบบอ่านหนังสือไม่ได้
เวลาอ่านหนังสือนานๆว่าจะคิดเองหิวข้าว
ร้อน
1 ไงพรุ่งนี้กินอะไรดีกินต้มยำกุ้ง
สปาเก็ตตี้แฮมเบอร์เกอร์ดีไหมอะไรอย่าง
เงี้ยอยู่มันไม่โฟกัสที่หนังสือไงก็เลย
อ่านหนังสือไม่ค่อยได้นะคะ
ขวาเลยก็เลยอ่านได้แค่ 30 นาที
ไอได้ค่ะแล้วครูฟ้าชอบอ่านหนังสืออะไรอะ
อย่างครูหญิงเนาะครูชอบอ่านหนังสืออัน
นี้เรียกหนังสือนิยายนิยายใช่ไหมคะ The
murder อะไรเนี่ย at  the อะไรก็ไม่รู้
อ่านไม่ออกนะคะสวยเป็นไรยายนะคะคนที่
เขียนก็คืออาคาธาตุคริสตี้ไม่อ่านเนี่ย
เป็นหนังสือนิยายแล้วก็ครูหญิงเนี่ยชอบ
อ่านหนังสือการ์ตูน
ไปนักเรียนเนี่ยการ์ตูนนะคะหนังสือ
การ์ตูนหมดแล้วอ่ะที่ครูหญิงชอบอ่าน
ครูฟ้าล่ะครูฟ้าชอบอ่านหนังสืออะไร
ลูกค้าก็
น้ำแข็ง 1 นาค่ะครูภาษากำลังหาหนังสือ
อยู่ใช่ไหมไทยค่ะแบบว่าชอบอ่านหนังสือ
นิยายเหมือนผู้หญิงค่ะแต่ว่าของฟ้าเป็น
เพอร์ซี่แจ็คสันนะค่ะเป็น
คู่ฟ้าทั้งหมดเนี่ยหนังสือทั้งหมดอันนี้
Percy  Jackson หรอคะให้หาเผื่ออาแจ๊ก
สันทั้งหมดเลยค่ะงูมีกี่เล่ม Percy
Jackson
งู Percy  Jackson
10 กว่าเล่มมั้งเพราะว่ากูฟ้ามีแบบ E
Book
มี ebook ที่อยู่ใน iPad แล้วก็มีหนังสือ
ที่อยู่ข้างนอกด้วยนะคะหนังสือสวยๆ
หนังสือแบบนี้เลยหนังสือแบบนี้นะฮะคนที่
จะสรรค์เยอะมากน้าเป็นแบบว่า 1  2 10เล่ม
ชนะ 10 เล่มขึ้นไป
ยก
แจ็กสันสมัยใช่ค่ะเอง Percy  Jackson ฟ้า
บอกว่ามีมากกว่าสิบเล่มก็จะเป็น Percy
Jackson  1  Percy  Jackson  2  3 มาก
กว่า 10 เล่มทรูฟ้าอ่าน Percy  Jackson
ทางหมดหรือยังคะค่ะก็อาจยังค่ะค่ะฟ้าอ่าน
ไป 6 เล่ม
หือก็คือครูฟ้าอ่านเล่มหนึ่งถึงแม่น 6 กู
ว่ะอ่านแล้วเล่ม 7 เล่ม 8 เล่ม 9 เล่ม 10
Miku ฝ้ายังไม่ได้อ่านยังไม่ได้อ่านใช่
ค่ะคุณแล้วก็ดูฟ้า
มีหนังสืออะไรที่ครูฟ้าชอบอ่านอีก
กำลังหาอยู่นะคะคะว่ามันเยอะ
นักเรียนบอกว่ารู้แล้วครูหญิงไม่ชอบอ่าน
หนังสือ
รถหญิงมีหนังสือนิยายมาของอาร์คาถ้าน้อง
อ่ะคะถ้าคริสตี้เขียนนะคะอาจารย์ธาตุ
คริสตี้เนี่ยเราก็บอกว่าเขาเป็นนักเขียน
เนาะนักเขียนเป็นแค่คนคุยจะมีรูปนักเขียน
ไหมนะคะนักเรียนเป็นคนเขียนหนังสือ
น้องอ่ะคะถ้าคริสต์ดีแต่ผู้หญิงคิดฮอดนะ
คะใช่ค่ะชอบกูพาก็อ่านหนังสือแบบผู้หญิง
ก็คือเป็นหนังสือเกี่ยวกับ Detective ใช่
ไหมคะแบบกระทะถ้าคริปปี้ gakupo โรชะล็อค
โฮล์มส์
เขียน hakuhodo นักเขียนเนี่ยมันเป็นนั่ง
เขียนนะคะอกาธาคริสตี้เนี่ยเป็นนักเขียน
ขอ
ไอฟ้าก็อ่านนิยายแต่ไม่ใช่ Percy  Jackson
ใช่ไหมคะเป็นนิยายแบบจะล็อคห่วงนี้
Sherlock  Holmes  act พื้นโปโล
ไหนคะหนังสือครูฟ้าสีฟ้ามี ebook
ดีมากนะคะนักเรียน
เป็นจะล็อคโฮล์มส์
ใช่คือเยอะมาก
อันนี้ทั้งกฎ Sherlock  Holmes เหรอคะคุณ
ฟ้ามีชล็อกโฟมด้วยแล้วก็มีเอ่ออาจจะฆ่า
คริสตี้ด้วยค่ะค่ะ
ใช่ค่ะกูฟ้าแบบมีหลายที่นะคะในโทรศัพท์ใน
iPad  Mac โทรศัพท์ไอโฟนใน iPad แล้วก็
ในคอมพิวเตอร์อย่างนี้ค่ะ
อันนี้หนังสืออะไรคะคุณฟ้ามันเป็นหนังสือ
S เตอรี่มั้ย
หยุด Three ล่ะสนุกนะอันนี้สนุกๆมากเวลา
ครูกะๆก็ฟ้าก็แบบรู้อยากรู้อยากรู้กะอ่าน
ๆนี้ก็คือเราคิดสนุกใช่ไหมคะอยากอ่าน
ก็เลยมีหนังสือใช้มีนคะหรือหนังสือ
หนังสือหนังสือเยอะ
แล้วครูฟ้าไม่อ่านหนังสือการ์ตูนเหรอคะ
มันคะนักเรียนอ่านหนังสือการ์ตูนนะคะมาหา
ก่อนกูฟ้าก็อ่านหนังสือการ์ตูนเนาะเวลา
ไหนคะหนังสือการ์ตูนของครูฟ้านิดนึงนะนี่
หาหนังสือการ์ตูน
ฟ้ามีหนังสือการ์ตูนมากๆนะแต่คนไทยคนไทย
อ่านหนังสือการ์ตูนของญี่ปุ่นสวยนี้เป็น
การ์ตูนญี่ปุ่นนะคะไม่ใช่การ์ตูนอเมริกา
แต่ละ Batman  Spiderman แล้วไม่คนไทยไม่
ค่อยได้อ่าน
สายไปแล้วการ์ตูนญี่ปุ่นชายฝั่งแล้วครู
ฟ้าครูฟ้าคิดว่าคนไทยนะถ้าไม่ใช้แค่ผู้
หญิงกับครูฟ้านะคะประเทศไทยใช่ไหมประเทศ
ไทยเนี่ยมีคนไทยนะมีผู้ชายไทยมีผู้หญิง
นั่งคนไทยเนี่ยประมาณเท่าไหร่คะอก 15
ล้านคนไหมใช่ค่ะคนไทยเหรอครูฟ้าคิดว่าคน
ไทยแหละ 65 ล้านคน
ชอบอ่านหนังสือไหม
ไม่
ไม่ค่ะหากคิดว่าคนไทยไม่ชอบอ่านหนังสือ
หรือนี่ใช่น้องเขาบอกว่าคนไทยน้ำเป็นผู้
ชายผู้ชายไทยผู้หญิงไทยแนทที่อายุประมาณ
13 ถึง
คุณให้ 22 แล้วกันและก็ถือว่ายังเป็น
เยาวชนอยู่นะคะ
13-22 นะเป็นคนไทยที่ชอบอ่านหนังสือ
ก็ไม่ใช่ครูฟ้าไม่ใช่ครูหญิง
แต่ตอกฟ้าอายุ 17  18  19  20  21 เนี่ย
กุมภาชอบอ่านหนังสือเขาก็ไว้แต่ถ้าคนไทย
ที่อายุ 23 ปีขึ้นไปเนี่ยชอบอ่านหนังสือ
น้อยลง
น้อยลงน้อยลงใต้เขาบอกว่าคนไทยอายุ 13
ถึง 22 ปีเนี่ย 1 วัน
1 วันนะอ่านหนังสือประมาณ
109 นาที
109 นาทีแต่ถ้าคนไทยที่อายุ 23 ปีขึ้น
ต่อไป
ไปเขียนตรงไหนดีแล้วก็ได้ 1 วัน
1 วัน
อ่านหนังสือเนี่ยแปดสิบนาที
80 นาทีอันนี้เด็กๆเด็กๆไทย 1 วันอ่าน
หนังสือ
109 นาทีพอเราโตขึ้นโตขึ้นเราก็อ่านน้อย
ลง
คิดว่าไม่มีเวลา
เพราะว่าทำงานไหมทำงานทำงานทำงานทำงานได้
ฝาทันมากๆไปออฟฟิศเนี้ยเดี๋ยวเบิก of  a
นี่แล้วก็แบบก็ไม่ค่อยอ่านหนังสือหรือไหม
แล้วก็ในโลกใช่ไหมในโลกของเราน่าจะโลก
น้องมีอเมริกาอารดาเม็กซิโกจีนญี่ปุ่น
ออสเตรเลียและในโลกของเรา
ก็ประเทศประเทศประเทศก็จะมีประเทศเนาะใน
โลกของเราเนี่ยประเทศที่อ่านหนังสือมากๆ
ก็ไม่ใช่ไทยไม่ใช่เอเชียแล้วคือประเทศ
อะไรคะผู้หญิงผู้หญิงเช็คบาร์เขาบอกว่า
ประเทศฟินแลนด์
ฟินแลนด์
อ่านหนังสือ
มากที่สุดก็ขอคิดว่าประเทศฟินแลนด์คน
ฟินแลนด์ชอบอ่านหนังสือ
ในคนไทยไม่ชอบนะคะเพราะอ่านการเป็นเล่ม
เนาะไสวนั่นแหละแต๋มไม่รู้ว่านักเรียนชอบ
อ่านหนังสือไหมอ่ะ
โป้นักเรียนก็คอมเม้นท์บอกครูได้นะคะว่า
นักเรียนชอบอ่านหนังสือหรือไม่ชอบอ่าน
หนังสือ
จ่ายหรือแล้วก็นักเรียนชอบอ่านหนังสือ
หรืออะไร
น้องผู้หญิงกับครูฟ้าชอบอ่านหนังสือ
การ์ตูน
สมัยนักเรียนอ่านทุกวันไหมคอมเม้นบอกได้
นะคะแต่วีดีโอนี้เนี่ยผู้หญิงกับครูฟ้า
ต้องไปแล้วนะคะแล้วเจอกันวีดีโอหน้าค่ะ
สวัสดีค่ะอ่ะ